tristesse et moi colère les syndicats de
police qui sont donc actuellement reçue
par jean castex attendent dégage du
premier ministre ils ont d'ailleurs
suspendu leur participation au goût de
la sécurité beaucoup d'entre eux
estiment ne pas être assez protégé c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir sur
le thème de la sécurité emmanuel macron
en at il fait assez et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec rocco contento
secrétaire départemental d'unité sgp
police fo paris qui est en direct avec
nous par téléphone avec un petit souci
technique malheureusement ne peut pas
vous à voir de visu rocco contento merci
à vous d'être malgré tout en direct
jean-michel miss député la république en
marge de la deuxième circonscription de
la loire bonsoir jean michel miss merci
d'être avec nous deux policiers tués en
l'espace de quinze jours et cet incident
ce soir à bordeaux dont on ne connaît
pas encore bien bien les circonstances
un il s'agirait d'une femme en état de
démence qui a finalement été tué après
avoir agressé un policier raconte un
taux c'est clairement un point de
non-retour qu'on a franchi ces derniers
jours en vous oui complètement on a
franchi un pan de retour surtout parce
que notre collègue éric masson a été
délibérément tué lors d'une intervention
de police comme toute relativement banal
savez il ya 25 ans ce qu'il fait les
policiers s'étaient les braqueurs de
banque qui étaient des personnes en
cavale qui avait 30 ans de de prison sur
la tête et là on constate que la police
ne fait plus peur est pire que ça ces
autorités de ce pays en pleine crise de
l'autorité de l'état et qui est encore
plus flagrante depuis plusieurs années
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument
au delà des tracts et des déclarations
d'intention qui est fait du président
des médecins gouvernement il faut
vraiment agir par des actes forts des
actes forts jean-michel miss vous êtes
d'accord vous comprenez cette
écoeurement absolue
de la police et que cette fois ci on ne
va certainement pas se contenter
d'effets d'annoncé il faut une des
changements en profondeur
oui j'ai non seulement je comprends mais
je partage ce qui vient d'être dit je
vois que vous voyons bien aujourd'hui
nous assistons à une montée de violence
par rapport aux forces de l'ordre
et ce régulièrement par rapport aux
policiers qui ont été attaqués et
assassiné avec une achetée sans nom
notamment je pensais avec l'assemblée
mais cette séquence n'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas coutume ce n'est pas seulement
le fait de des quelques années passées
on a eu évidemment stéphanie montferrer
à rambouillet mai mais si on remonte
simplement à 2016 avec le l'assassinât
noté jean baptiste salins et de jessica
schneider aubergenville nous voyons qu
aujourd'hui effectivement de l'uniforme
l'autorité que représente mes policiers
ou les gendarmes ne font plus peur pour
un chaton d'individus de qui n'hésitent
pas à passer à l'acte et de manière non
seulement violente mais qui n'hésitent
pas à assassiner sans états d'âme des
hommes et des femmes qui sont au service
de votre protection encore content je
vais vous faire écouter avant de vous
faire réagir ce qu'on pense julien bayou
secrétaire nationale europe ecologie les
verts qui revient sur le manque
d'effectifs ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il y ait un manque de policiers c'est
la droite qui s'érige en donneuse de
leçons sur la sécurité qui les a retirés
avec la doctrine du non remplacement
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
voilà on a perdu 15 ans aujourd'hui en
2021 vous avez moins de policiers
nationaux et de gendarmes qu en 2007
alors que la population augmente et
emmanuel macron est en retard puisqu'il
s'en est rendu compte que très récemment
jean-michel mise toujours ce manque
d'effectifs les parties se renvoient la
responsabilité à chaque fois la clé
elle est là notamment je pense que ce
n'est pas la seule réponse l'autorité de
la police est la priorité
on peut bien mettre autant de policiers
pour eux c'est un satan d'individus
n'occupe heures et non plus le respect
de l'uniforme je crois que ça n'y
changera rien quant à monsieur bayou je
suis quand même assez choqué pour pas
dire profondément choqué de ces propos
venant d'un individu de personnes qui
ont passé leur temps pendant un an à
compter c'est l'autorité de la police à
toutes les manifestations prenant fait
et cause pour ceux qui les attaquent
je pense que la décence voudrait
aujourd'hui ils prennent un temps de
recueillement et ne tiennent pas de tels
propos je crois que ce n'est pas la
seule raison
effectivement le la baisse d'effectif on
peut on peut se passer la balle les uns
les autres
mais cela ne répondra pas je ne crois
pas que ce soit la demande de nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens veulent que
l'autorité de la police et de la
gendarmerie et notamment des forces de
sécurité mais pas seulement
d'une manière générale tout ce qui
représente une autorité en france tout
ce qui peut représenter finalement
l'état d'une manière ou d'une autre
soient protégés ils soient accompagnés
de manière beaucoup plus forte également
pour la virer chami elle pâtit également
un individu seul face à des personnes
totalement contraire aux principes de la
république
il faut que cela cesse et ce n'est pas
des discours qui vont changer cela mais
bien effectivement une nouvelle est un
nouvel état d'esprit qui permettra ca
d'éviter de voir qu'aujourd'hui nous ne
souhaitons pas on en laisse et la rue et
leur laisser le champ libre
jean-michel mise justement à ce débat de
fond ni sur six de plus en plus avec ce
thème récurrent de la sécurité qui
devient éminemment politique un vin de
trois semaines après la publication
d'une tribune controversé signé par les
militaires à la retraite s'insurgeant
contre le délitement de la france
valeurs actuelles en publie aujourd'hui
nouvelle pour la survie de notre pays en
distille écrite cette fois-ci par des
militaires d'actifs sous couvert
d'anonymat et qui a déjà recueilli plus
de 160 mille signataires regardez une
nouvelle tribune de militaires publié
dimanche sur le site de l'hebdomadaire
valeurs actuelles
appelle le président de la république
les ministres les parlementaires et
officiers généraux à prendre leurs
responsabilités pour éviter à la france
une guerre civile qui couve nourrie par
la violence et le communautarisme
les auteurs sont tenus de garder
l'anonymat
hommes et femmes militaires en activité
de toutes les armées de tous les grades
de toutes les sensibilités
si nous ne pouvons pas réglementairement
nous exprimer à visage découvert il nous
est tout aussi impossible de nous taire
d'après le texte
une partie d'entre eux a servi à
l'étranger en zone de guerre afghanistan
mali centre afrique ou ailleurs certains
riant laisser des camarades ils ont
offert leur peau pour détruire l'islam
isme auquel vous fait des concessions
sur notre sol la plupart ont pris part
explique-t-il à l'opération sentinelle
lancée à la suite des attentats de
janvier 2015
nous avons vu de nos yeux les banlieues
abandonnées les accommodements avec la
délinquance nous avons subi les
tentatives d'instrumentalisation de
plusieurs communautés religieuses pour
qui la france ne signifie rien rien
qu'un objet de sarcasmes de mépris voire
de haine ce lundi l'état major des
armées a tenu à se démarquer de ses
propos un rappel ferme sera fait par le
commandement sur le respect du devoir de
réserve les armées sont apolitiques et
d'une fidélité absolue au président élu
la tribune des jeunes militaires fait
suite à une première publiée par le même
si le 21 avril et dans laquelle des
généraux à la retraite au grade et
autres militaires entendaient dénoncer
le délitement de la france raconte anne
tôt quelle est la réaction du policier
que vous êtes vous voyez là une forme de
soutien
finalement pour votre profession et
surtout la tâche qui vous incombent et
qui vous encombre et si les choses
devaient parfois tourner mal comme
semble penser ces militaires où vous
trouvez vous la démarche inquiétante
dont je trouve pas la démarche du tout
inquiétante mais c'est vraiment
révélateur nar yale balej dans d'autres
pays pour que une tribune deux tribunes
de militaires à la retraite est aussi
d'activ fils tiré le signal d'alarmé sur
les problématiques importantes notamment
de sécurité qui sont à dante et je crois
qu'ils étaient les dix mois de déboires
je n'ai pas vu ça depuis très très
longtemps
on partage aussi ce qui est dit et je
voudrais ajouter un mot par rapport aux
sujets d'avancé que vous savez vous
pouvez mettre 3000 5000 effectifs de
plus ce sont les terrains ce qui est
important c'est le signal que j'ai
décidé qu'on donne pas non et c'est la
réponse pénale la réponse pénale qui
doit être immédiate lorsque des
personnes agressent des forces de
sécurité intérieure faysal puis
d'importants alors se propose de parler
justement avant de parler de la forme de
cette tribune propose d'écouter un
gérald darmanin ce sujet il s'agit de
genre anonyme
c'est ça le courage d'être anonyme
quelle drôle de société courage aux que
celle qui donne la parole à des anonymes
on se croirait sur les réseaux sociaux
donc je n'ai pas lu la tribune des
militaires mais je crois savoir parce
que j'ai beaucoup de militaires dans ma
famille tout quand on est militaire on
ne fait pas ce genre de choses en
cachette à la petite semaine
votre réaction jean michel millet miss
les militaires sortent de la foule
écoutez je pense que les manière
générale on ne règle pas ce type de
problème par des propos anonymes porté
sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense que les réseaux sociaux sont
justement l'une des causes des
difficultés contre aujourd'hui parce que
le pseudonymat qui est donné un certain
nombre d'individus crée de la confusion
et craie pour des ailes pour les pour
nos concitoyens qui parfois sont en en
des endroits l'impression que
effectivement s'attendre de deux
questions qui se posent nous et
trouveront des réponses mais je crois
que les réseaux sociaux ne doivent pas
être le lieu du débat public ce sont des
lieux de l'information des lieux des
changes mais je pense que dans une
démocratie la démocratie se vit à visage
découvert je pense que les militaires
qui souhaite tenir des propos il y en a
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de militaires de
deux qualités qui sont retraite qui
peuvent s'exprimer qu'ils peuvent être
porte parole de leurs camarades
je pense qu'il ya des moyens je pense
plus utile que efficace de de contribuer
au débat public qu'à travers des
tribunes unis jean-michel miss sk pas
une possibilité aussi de se poser la
question à l'envers peut-être que cette
démarche est choquant peut-être qu'elle
est inquiétante mais comme le disait
rocco contento ya quelques instants elle
révèle aussi un malaise et peut-être
voilà des voix qui ne sont pas
suffisamment entendue dans ce pays
peut-être faut-il les entendre oui je
parle essentiellement de la fin je pense
que la forme n'est pas bonne cela ne
veut pas dire que ce qui est dit dans
cette tribune ou d'une manière plus
générale nous sommes en contact les élus
de la république et dont je fais partie
nous ne sommes pas sourds les aveugles
il nous entendons ce qui nous est dit
parfois de manière confidentielle
je crois que ce débat doit effectivement
avoir lieu il n'est pas sain dans une
démocratie que son côté que des
serviteurs de la france soit considère
qu'ils ne puissent pas s'exprimer
autrement qu'à travers des tribus des
anonymes donc je pense qu'il faut ouvrir
le débat voire dialogue permettre
justement parce que cette expression
puisse se faire de manière plus
transparente et puis normal qu'elles
puissent nourrir un débat en société et
je pense que le modèle que nous
souhaitons tous ce modèle de du creuset
républicain ce modèle qui fait la
démocratie ne soit pas supplée dans
l'esprit de certains par une addition de
communauté l'addition de communautés ne
doit pas faire la france ce qui fait la
france c'est justement l'intégration
dans la république et je pense que ce
débat là est tout à fait légitime et on
se sent cela j'entends un certain nombre
de propos qui sont portées que ce soit
par des militaires ou par par la société
civile d'une manière beaucoup plus large
les militaires ne ne sont pas différents
ce sont des sons avec des civils bouffer
des militaires rocco contento cette
tribune la deuxième pour vous allez le
reflet d'une faillite
les gouvernements du gouvernement actuel
mais d autres gouvernements qui ont
précédé celui ci le problème sinon je
savais c'est que on a eu une crise de
l'autorité de l'autorité de l'état et
qui malheureusement a grillé notre pays
et qui atteint son paroxysme or
concernant utilitaire vous savez ces
courageuses qui font parce que je vous
rappelle que les militaires que soient
les gendarmes ou les personnels de
l'armée ont un devoir de réserve absolu
ils n'ont pas de représentants du
personnel et il risque une révocation le
kdc en 6x t on pour qu'il le fasse je
pense que vraiment il y a comme je vous
le dis à un malaise après bon sur la
forme on peut en discuter mais sur le
fond de ce qui est dit nous les
policiers nous validons parce que il est
vrai que ont malheureusement en
témoignent les milliers de blessés que
nous avons chaque année
je vous rappelle qu'en 15 ans des
policiers du comté policiers ont doublé
et les premières victimes des attaques
contre les personnes ce sont nous les
forces de l'ordre donc comme comme je
vous le dis il faut réagir le président
lui même dans son discours je les
écoutais hier jeudi plus exactement où
ils étaient 1000 à parler de la réponse
pénale qui n'était pas au rendez vous
donc là dessus c'est un signal qu'il a
donnée maintenant il faut faire en sorte
que des réponses pénales soit faite que
par rapport aux agressions de policiers
des peines minimales je parle pas de
tels plans chez attention des peines
minimales en dessous desquels on ne
pourra pas aller parce que si on donne
pas à ces signaux ces bons signaux eh
bien ça va donner une habilité aux
délinquants qui vont continuer à
commettre leur délit en toute impunité
moi je rappelle que j'ai des collègues
qui ont été agressés par des délinquants
et dont ces délinquants n'ont écopé que
d'un rappel à la loi
imaginez ce très mauvais signal qu'on
bonne ça va les confronter à continuer
avec l'essai des policiers jean-michel
nice le mot de la fin pour vous
clairement votre majorité aujourd'hui
responsabilité plus importante que
jamais bien évidemment puisque nous
sommes comme vous de responsabilité donc
il nous appartient d'apporter des
réponses à la fois effectivement aux
policiers aux gendarmes et à tous les
détenteurs de l'autorité qui sont
victimes d'agressions
on va avoir malheureusement d'assassinât
dans les incidents leurs fonctions mais
également nos concitoyens qui évidemment
attendre de de l'état une réponse ferme
qui permettent de garantir la sécurité
des biens et des personnes
c'est quand ma première vocation de
l'état dans un pays la première des
libertés c'est d'assurer la sécurité des
biens et des personnes
les choix que sa priorité on va faire
avec les lois sur la sécurité globale
qui met en place justement en continuant
de sécurité et je pense que une partie
du problème et je crois que ça a été
évoqué nous en avons conscience
puisqu'une loi sur sur justement là la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
arrive à l'assemblée nationale et il
faut que je continue de sécurité passe
par une réponse pénale adaptée
cette réponse pénale doit être immédiate
et proportionnée aux faits je crois que
ce que nous nos concitoyens n'accepte
pas c'est de voir des individus
commettent des faits délinquance qu'il
soit petit ou plus important est
finalement rentrer chez eux en argot
l'autorité judiciaire d'autorité delà de
la police est finalement l'autorité de
l'état
mais je crois que cela il faut y mettre
un terme pour que le premier ministre
comme vous l'avez rappelé reçoit en ce
moment même les représentants des forces
de police à l'hôtel matignon le
président république je pense
s'exprimera dans dans sur ces questions
là également
et puis bien évidemment de toute manière
nous savons l'année qui est devant nous
est une allée en jeu politique très fort
nous savons que la sécurité prendra une
place important mais je crois que cela
est normal parce que ça correspond à une
attente profonde de nos concitoyens
merci en tout cas tous les deux recours
ont tantôt jean-michel miss d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france